regis on pages are no longer going to be
bond
welcome to sidetrack your scifi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
so here i am on my holidays but still
doing videos for you people it's because
i love you
well
here's the story
last week i told you that reggie john
page was being earmarked to take over as
bond
that caused a little bit of controversy
because reggie's on page is not the
typical image of what you consider james
bond to be
he came to fame basically during the
bridgeton series for netflix and has
declined going to back
to a second series in bridgeston because
he's now decided to become a movie star
he's actually already got a few parts
he's going to be in the new dungeons
dragons film with chris pine um he's
going to be in gray man with um a couple
other things that's going to be a big
netflix movie next year
um
he's actually also been cast though
as the saint
as simon templar
now
this came as a bit of a surprise to mgm
executives i'm told
as you know if you're a regular
sidetracker i have a few sources in
around mgm and they talk to me and
they've basically told me that they knew
nothing about this
the contract negotiations with reggie
john page had started for him to become
the next james bond and this
announcement on friday that he was going
to become the saint
came completely out of the blue
it has put them into a bit of a tail
spin
apparently reggie jane sean's um
representatives don't see any reason why
this should be a problem
why can't he be the saint and james bond
roger moore was
well james bond people are saying no
the parts are very very similar and also
we want to crack on with james bond soon
when are you going to supposed to do
this if you're doing both parts so
there's going to be a
a lot of problems
so basically
reggie jane page has shot himself in the
foot he's basically took the biggest one
of the biggest parts
in
hollywood
and decided to do the saints instead
so let's see what happens it's
apparently not completely dead in the
water right now but as good as
a big problem with this news about
reggie going over to the saint
is that they'd put all their eggs in his
basket
as it were
they genuinely thought this was going to
be the next james bond contract
negotiations had started
now it turns out that's not going to
happen and not going to be the case
mgm executives and the james bond
executive producers have no idea who the
next james bond is going to be
they want a young james bond they want
somebody that's going to start the
franchise again a pre double 07 james
bond
well
that really does limit your
options
and a lot of the names that have been
banded about
just aren't going to happen now like
idris elba and
tom hardy and people like this
so where are we going to go now
this is definitely
put the executives in charge of james
bond into a massive tailspin
they're not happy
reggie will almost certainly not be born
there
but let's see what happens
but the big question is who the hell is
if you're new to the channel please like
subscribe with the bell notification it
really helps us out and
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker
hit the join button
as always guys see you safe and uh look
at my view
see you next time
[Music]
you